foreign
[Music]
yes hey dude now that 2022 is is in the
books a distant memory it's time to
catch up on what kind of climate
occurred in that year and to do that we
do that we're going to our our man about
town for climate yes our man about the
globe the global town uh Gavin Schmidt
Gavin thanks for coming back to StarTalk
thanks for having me uh great to be here
yeah so you're a director of NASA's
Goddard Institute for space studies
which is right here in Manhattan in New
York City uh it doesn't have a huge
storefront like Kennedy Space Center or
NASA headquarters or JPL but you guys
are you are the branch of NASA that
concerns itself with weather and climate
not only on Earth but on any planet that
has it is that a fair uh overview yeah
that's uh that's exactly right I mean we
started off as uh as the theoretical
Division and we've moved uh very much
into uh Into Climate observations uh
understanding those uh climate modeling
uh trying to work out why things are
changing and then what might be
happening in the future
um and now that has that has drifted off
into
um exoplanet climate um and climate so
yeah you just take you just taken over
the universe now
I was happy to give you Earth in the
solar system right no I thought
Starbucks was aggressive with their
experience
it turns out it turns out the physics of
uh of the climate on the trappist-1e is
the same as the physics of the climate
on earth and the same as the physics of
climate a Venus 3 billion years ago and
so we can use the same understanding the
same tools uh to explore all of them wow
so you're also a pi principal
investigator on the model e Earth system
now what is that uh so so that's our uh
that's the framework that we use for
doing the climate modeling so it has it
has modules for the ocean and the
atmosphere and clouds and dust particles
and all the interactions between them uh
and you can move it around right so you
can move it around the university you
can make the planet smaller you can
change the kind of sun that you're
orbiting around you can change the orbit
you can have it be tidally these are
control knobs basically to test the
causes and effects of changes that's
right and then you can change the amount
of greenhouse gases you can change the
amount of air pollution you can Wobble
the Earth's orbit
um and then you can just see you know
what what what do you predict is going
to come out of that and uh yeah okay so
Chuck you know what's going on here yeah
these are this is the start of a
simulation of a whole other universe and
maybe we our knobs are getting turned by
Gavin's that are aliens right
so so Gary tell me about the 2022 and
and the climate there were some major
climate events around the world and but
first let's start out how did it rank
among the sort of the warmest years ever
on record
it was one of those uh so
it was uh yeah again another top 10 year
uh the exact ranking uh was uh fifth or
sixth depending on uh a couple of like
very Minor Details that don't really
matter uh and so you're looking at you
know the last the last nine years or the
warmest nine years on record uh this
decade is by far the warmest decade on
record wait wait on record since when uh
so our instrumental records right so so
using weather stations and ocean ship
measurements and boys uh to go back we
can go back to about the mid 19th
century
um before that you have to use things
like tree rings and Ice cores and uh
Cave records and other and other stuff
but uh uh in the record that we have
since the 19th century these are by far
the warmest ears and this is the warmest
decade uh we think
uh adding that data on that this is
likely to have been the warmest for for
actually many thousands of years
um and conceivably uh many hundreds of
thousands of years and how can how much
can we implicate those facts in major
climactic events such as Pakistan was a
third of Pakistan was underwater last
year yeah I mean yeah and they're still
recovering what what's
so uh I know I know people are resistant
to say this caused that but we can speak
statistically about it correct yeah we
can so uh the warming that we've seen
right so we've seen about two degrees
Fahrenheit warming since the late 19th
century that is enough to be impacting
the weather it's enough to be impacting
the frequency and intensity of heat
waves uh it's enough to impact the
intensity of rainfall and and you know
we've been seeing that hurricane Ian
Pakistan
um uh now in in California uh we are
seeing uh that that is enough to
implicate uh the rise in sea level
um and the changes in Arctic sea ice all
of these things are linked to that
Global mean temperature change that
we've seen and that changes because of
us is the rise in sea level a
combination of the water getting warmer
as well as uh glacial ice melting back
into the oceans that's pretty much it
yeah so the water is getting warmer so
we're putting into the uh we're putting
heat into the ocean like nobody's
business I mean like you know if I told
you the unit that they measure that is
it's in Zeta joules
yeah people say
z-e-t-t-a the metric prefix above Peta
Jewels which is way above it goes away
above yeah so it's 10 to the power 22
joules right that's that's the that's
the unit that we're measuring these
changes in so that's a very big number
so that's causing the that's causing the
ocean to expand right that's the raising
sea level and then the heat itself is
melting mounting glaciers around the
world it's melting uh Greenland it's
melting Antarctica and so all of that
ice that was ice is now water water and
that's raising the sea level as well all
right so so that does sea level rise
actually
contribute to temperature increase
because some would say no that that it
seems like it should cool it down if
you're putting frozen water of water
that was recently frozen into the ocean
that that would cool things off
well but we're putting in lots more heat
so it's just melting the ice so
um uh no it's so that doesn't cause
temperature rise but it does impact the
damages caused by storms right so the
sea level rises the storm surges become
more damaging it's uh it's pretty it's
pretty safe forward so Gavin I think a a
healthy skeptic would say
oh come on now how is it that you you
get to blame
heavy rains as well as drought on the
same phenomena exactly how how can you
very suspicious yeah yeah what's what's
the key the key thing to remember
particularly about rainfall is it's not
raining everywhere at the same time
right so uh as things get warmer uh
there's generally more water vapor in
the atmosphere you can hold a lot more
water in the atmosphere so that when you
have a frontal system when you have a
rainfall event when you have an
atmospheric River you're delivering a
lot more water vapor uh potentially and
so that comes out in the statistics of
rainfall so when it rains you're seeing
a shift towards the more intense uh
rainfall uh amount so we we've did you
use the term atmospheric River I didn't
yes what is that
so uh it's really neat if you look at
Satellite photographs or satellite
imagery of water vapor right it isn't
just like a blob right you know there's
more water in the tropics right you know
because it's warmer and less water vapor
in the uh in the in the polls but the
pattern of water vapor is very
interesting and what you get is these uh
they're called atmospheric Rivers
there's these bands of very uh very
moisture flows moisture very very
moisture Laden bits of air they look
like filaments that come out of the
tropics uh they kind of spiral around
they get caught up in the storm systems
and then when they intersect with the
continent uh you get what we've seen in
California uh very recently you get
absolutely massive downpours and uh and
you can just you can trace these things
for thousands of miles and so they look
like they're rivers in the atmosphere
right so that's what it's all about and
uh speaking of California one of the
people were just like well you know you
can't have it both ways you can't
and complain that we're in a drought
forever and then when we get all this
water now you're complaining that you
know there's too much water but what
they don't understand is that the the
global warming creates these conditions
where the ground because of drought
becomes cement like so that when you get
the water the water doesn't seep into
the ground the way it's supposed to and
that that actually creates all this
incredible damage
so that's that's a great example another
example is places where you've had
wildfires so so where you've had
wildfires along the the mountain uh
sides that actually uh kind of makes the
soil uh less
um cohesive and so when it rains you get
much bigger landslides yeah so we saw
that in in Montecito uh you know a
couple of years ago they had some fires
there were some big rains massive
landslides so we're seeing similar
things happening uh the these things are
uh are pretty complex but yeah no
they're adding to uh the the damages and
the impacts of this and what what about
the co emission CO2 emission was there
some measure of that for the year uh
yeah unfortunately we um uh we had a bit
of a slump which was good right during
the pandemic when people uh no one was
going anywhere right Transportation
exactly so Transportation was much less
we're making less stuff there was there
was a lot less emissions about uh I
think about a 16 drop uh in 2020 it kind
of picked up again in 2021 and then in
2022 we're back at uh record levels of
emissions of carbon dioxide all right so
okay baby
all right
no it's not it's it's crazy all right so
is there some Tipping Point that we
should watch out for
there's lots of thresholds in the system
there isn't I mean you've got the model
you've got the model yeah
tweak knobs and say oh my gosh well we
we do that and uh but uh
uh we don't talk about those in public
I was going to say I feel like Gavin's
hiding something you know
something tells me he is not letting on
some information it's the emergency it's
the emergency button on his site that
says kiss your ass goodbye
we really try not to do that uh so you
know we're we're looking at all these
things we're looking at you know lots of
places where there could be thresholds
crossed we're looking at changes in the
uh in the in the permafrost uh in the in
the Arctic regions uh we're looking at
changes in the Amazon we're looking at
changes in the ocean currents but but do
you have do you have a knob that
controls the melting of permafrost that
then exposures decomposing vegetation
that would then release methane to add
to the CO2 Greenhouse yeah so that's
exactly the kind of thing that we're
looking at
um and so right now we're seeing a
little bit of that but not enough uh to
really be concerning the big changes in
methane seem to be related both to oil
and gas activities drilling pipelines
all right now you bombed us out for 10
minutes here uh is there anything
hopeful we can offer our viewers and
listeners
silence yeah
I don't mean to laugh it's sad but right
or it says or is it like you've won a
month vacation in Bora Bora the bad news
is you've got two weeks to live well
right no it's not it's it's not that bad
what we know uh from our understanding
of what's been going on the fingerprints
have changed is that what we said before
the the trends up until now have been up
to us but the good news is that the
trends going forward from now they're
also up to us right so what we do
collectively makes a difference like if
we stay if we stopped emitting carbon
dioxide tomorrow which isn't going to
happen but if we did uh then
temperatures wouldn't keep on Rising
we'd be pretty much flat we'd just stay
where we are right now okay and so so
the difference between that and what's
actually going to happen is is our
choices you know how how we choose to
power our society how we choose to get
around how we choose to build our cities
our buildings uh our infrastructure that
those those choices are are ours and we
have agency we can make better decisions
and you know there's lots of people
making decisions at all sorts of levels
right there's there's individual
consumers and parents and citizens and
um voters and letter writers and all of
those people can influence the people
who are making decisions that are going
to impact those emissions going forward
thank you thank you so much for gosh
it's so great to hear a scientist who is
uh well-versed and credible say exactly
that because what you did was frame this
as a holistic problem with solutions
that have to approach it that way
instead of saying things like well you
know individual uh efforts don't really
do anything to solve this problem and
and I hate when I hear you know
scientists speak like that because I
think what the public hears is well
forget it not effort but yeah different
effort forget it forget it because
there's nothing I can do but what you're
saying is everybody should do everything
let's do it all
right we we wear multiple hats and I've
seen some of yours so yeah I know that
that's true uh we have a hat as a
consumer we have a hat as an advocate as
a as a as somebody that causes trouble
or we have
um you know you're a voter you're a
you're a you're a a customer you know
you you you have many many different
roles and the more that we can kind of
yeah activate those roles uh to help
people make better decisions the happier
we're going to be I think so so uh Gavin
I like the way you framed that because
another way to think about it is let's
say aliens came to Earth and decided to
pump CO2 into our atmosphere to smoke us
out we would say we would cry foul and
we would we would assemble all the
military and all possible forces to
defeat this enemy that's trying to warm
our Earth and whereas we're a warming
Earth so so my gosh we actually have
power to change this yeah it's not being
exacted upon us from outside the calls
are coming from inside the house
the hard the horror the horror so so uh
Gavin thanks for updating us on this
past year and so what you're saying is
floods droughts
um this is all the new normal at the
intensities that we've been seeing and
if we don't do something about it it'll
do something about it for us
um
maybe maybe slightly differently I mean
so we've always had floods and heat
waves and things but but what's
happening now is that the extra warmth
that we put in the system is juicing
those systems so so the heat waves are
being Juiced right so they're they're
stronger and more intense than they used
to be the rainfall is being Juiced it's
more intense than it used to be the
droughts even if we can't predict how
droughts are really going to evolve uh
for very long uh those droughts are
being made more intense because of the
extra heating it's drying out the soils
uh more than they would have done and
this two degree change that's an average
but what would what is the difference in
temperature equatorially versus the
Arctic yeah so that's that's a great
question so so the two degrees
Fahrenheit is is the overall Globe right
so what we see is that on land it's
warming by about three degrees
Fahrenheit uh and on Ocean about 0.8
something like that
um uh and in the uh in the northern
hemisphere it's warming more than in the
southern hemisphere because there's more
land and it's warming most of all at
about three and a half to four times the
rate of the global warming uh in the
Arctic and so things there are really
changing very very quickly so the Arctic
is there's four five six degrees warmer
in the Arctic is that what you're saying
yeah in the last uh last 30 to 40 years
yeah right right right okay so it's not
just two degrees everywhere just to be
clear right right and isn't that always
the kit the place that you need it not
to be the most distant place that is the
worst
the Glaciers are in a hurry exactly all
right I think we got to call it quits
there damn so Gavin get you on the horn
a year from now and you better give us
some good news
I you know I you know my fingers are
crossed but I I think that next year I
will give
you the same no no no no no no no no all
right so then it's up to the rest of us
all right let's see yeah we'll do what
we can uh at every level like you said
it's not just are you using gas versus
electricity but are you writing to
members of Congress are you buying
products that reflect this need are you
are you talking about this with your
friends and family are you talking about
this at your school or making it real
making it real making it real and and
and then responding to it because it's
real right yeah yeah so all right Gavin
okay you get you get back to your
modeling
your modeling career
my modeling career was just cut short at
an early age Okay
but well I'm delighted to learn of this
Model E Earth System model yeah it'll
give you some power of understanding uh
if not detail prediction certainly
generalized sense of uh what the causes
and effects are of our actions or
inaction exactly that's that's exactly
what they're for fate of our
civilization all right uh Gavin always
good to have you Chuck good to have you
there too it's a pleasure this has been
another start talk explainer with
climate scientist Gavin Schmidt Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
foreign
[Music]